[Music]
combat talk with the king this is a long
road folks this is the fight that Andrew
weeds thought wasn't gonna happen or
he's trying not to make it happen how
they wanted to do it
he kicked any scream then he yelled you
know they don't understand when you beat
the champ there's a rematch clause in
there the rematch clause is we're gonna
have to run that one back there blood
you gonna have to make sure that you
know we get this done ain't gonna be
like that you'ii go be easy so Anthony
Joshua got upset in the first fight
buying the Andy Ruiz jr. now Andy was
jr. was a last minute replacement for a
fighter that tested positive that was
supposed to fire Anthony Joshua we
already know yada yada yada
right so the rematch and the Ruiz wanted
to have it in New York City now the
fight was supposed to take place in
September October but they started going
through litigation and fighting and then
Andy Louise found out that um nah this
is lock stock and barrel you won't do
this fight where Eddie her says has its
own his own and the zone is gonna take
this fight to wherever the biggest bucks
are so guess who came a-calling Saudi
Arabia came a-calling Saudi Arabia came
with the big bucks for what they feel is
the biggest fight that they can catch
they could promote somebody fighters
they could put on one of the most
anticipated fights of the year this is
not many times heavyweights get a chance
to get that run back right back you know
so now that we get to run back right
back everybody's anticipating this so a
lot of talk coming up to this fight has
been
what is it uh Anthony Joshua losing
weight and everybody thought and he was
losing a whole bunch of weight so people
thought you know trainers that you
talked to and other boxers said that you
know Andy we should be the same two 6255
ish to keep that that that there statute
so you can absorb a punch and come at
them okay and everybody always
criticized AJ for being too muscle-bound
looking like a weight lifter I criticize
time as much as well because I'm gonna
use on Olympic champion he was a little
bit slimmer but he was younger too you
understand so I'm going to give you the
background on both fighters going in I'm
going to give you how I would fight each
individual fighter and then I'm going to
give you exactly what the outcome should
be the background behind Anthony Joshua
the former champion was everybody felt
that he was given a gimme
in his first heavyweight championship
fight and he subsequently went on from
there and you know systematically
gathered belts along the way fighting
people that we thought that he couldn't
be or will have trouble with Anthony
Joshua is an Olympian he is an
accomplished fighter in the amateur
ranks when it comes to professional
ranks there was a lot of doubts and
questions about him his boxing IQ and
his chin so all that got exposed when he
for Anthony a week and he was junior now
Andy Ruiz jr. was always looked at as a
middle tier journeyman that can give a
height air fighter some difficulties on
the right night so lightning struck Andy
we've got the phone call from a baby big
big baby Millar tested positive for
three different banned substances and
got kicked off the card so instead of
in the car to the side see this is the
problem when you fight on the zone and
they have to have this card this is paid
for advertisement is paid for stuff is
paid for so this fight must go on
so they scrambled and they got a fighter
and they got one of the fighters that
was off the list and a new me a lot of
people was like who is this guy and
after they saw his body they was like
all the Pillsbury Doughboy and the jokes
ensued but to be honest with you eight
weeks out and here just got out of a
fight and he was still in relatively
good shape going into this fight he
stood a better chance than most he's
been fighting for a very long time he
probably has at least in fight
experience 13 more years in age a
professionally probably he just wasn't
given opportunities to display his
talents so on the biggest night of his
life
he dug deep and he pulled off a very
good upset now to me why it's not the
greatest upset in boxing history the
greatest boxing upset in boxing history
it has to be because of both people are
on equal footings and one is a heavily
favored champion and then an upset
happens like when Lennox Lewis fought
Hasim Rahman or when Lennox Lewis fought
all of them a call
those were upsets those were oh my god
are you serious those was one shot
bangers
now Andy Ruiz got caught with Anthony
Joshua's left Hulk hybrid uppercut
knocked him down he got up and he
proceeded to go to work he says I'm here
we might as well fight right and he
proceeded to put his hands on Anthony
Joshua and he gave him a good go
he caught the champ the champ got wobbly
and the rest is history now leading up
to this fight I believe that these two
champions because once you're a champion
you always a champion in my eyes
took the role to this fight in two
different directions Anthony Joshua was
unfocused going into the the first fight
with Andy Luiz jr. that's you know like
eight weeks out I mean come on now you
know 818 days some some something
something crazy that you know they had
to scramble to get the fight together
this is not the guy that he had all the
animosity in the build-up for and he was
unassuming so of course he let his guard
now not taking anything away from Andy
Wiis jr. but Anthony Joshua look this
interested and wasn't about everything
that he needed to be about so Andy was
jr. knew the opportunity that he had in
front of him
and he seized that opportunity now this
fight leading into this fight I saw
somebody going off of that oh it's a
rocky story and people want to talk to
you and people want to be in your ear
this is the time brother when you're
supposed to buckle down buckle in strap
and hit that gym the next day cuz the
champ is coming he want what you stole
you're not gonna take them by surprise
this time you must earn this one a
hundred percent not saying that you
didn't earned it the last time
but the champ is coming this time
champion saw the tape so if you want to
be a true champion you must defend your
title Anthony Joshua has defend his
title of numerous times and picked up
belts as well so we're not gonna dismiss
him as some bum it's his chin top notch
I don't think so I never did I thought a
bright clicks go a little bit younger
beats him but we're not gonna dismiss
his accomplishments because his
accomplishments was made and forged
through fire and blood so he's in this
ring and he's ready
Anthony Joshua has slimmed down no long
is that giant muscle
master tires him out long no no longer
is that giant muscle mass that shortens
his punches
it looks longer he looks leaner pause
and he looks like he's ready to give a
concerned effort in this fight that's
all you ever want from your fighter a
very concerned effort I looked at his
training camp spoke to a couple of
people I saw the hair nappy the bed
scruffy
oh boy is digging deep old boy is going
into dark chambers in his mind he's not
looking at photo shoots he don't care
about no photo shoots he's not looking
to do no interviews actually AJ is
annoyed
AJ actually once wore andylou Ruiz is
smiling Andy Ruiz is looking at this as
yeah he got it in the bag is to come up
he's listening to all his people that's
in his camp everybody who's eating off
of your plate now that you're a champion
you're buying Bentley's you're having
parties
eating pizza did you eat your way out of
your championship a lot Buster Douglas
did you allow this little Fame and go to
your head AJ realize that nobody is your
friend when your box and you lose who's
in your corner when you got your head
down and your pride kicked in who's
there your woman your best friend your
trainer where's your friends at Anthony
Joshua learned a hard lesson there is no
friends when you win it I mean when you
lose him there's only friends when you
win it you see Andy Louise just got new
family members new best friends picking
up mercedes-benz
you're shopping but you're not watching
what's going on maybe you don't care but
this is how I would fight you Andy
I will come in Lina I will keep you at
the distance of the jab I will shoot the
right hand only when necessary I would
throw probably at least 3040 jabs around
soften you up drop the right hand on any
time you get close I will tie you up
grab you and lean on you stretch your
back out see if you did any core work
see how your hamstrings doing see if I
can get you to pull a muscle while you
fighting test your stamina I'm viola an
eighth ninth round when you ripe and
ready then I start putting in that work
on you start going to the body bringing
everything up the middle uppercuts left
hooks right hooks jab sidestep push you
off no hugging in because when you want
to hug then I don't want to hug now in a
fight and I will knock you out smooth by
the 10th round cold I'll make you quit
on your stool now if I'm fighting aging
this fight I come in
2:55 [ __ ] if I was 260 something before
I come in 255 a little bit more roadwork
keep that stammer because I'm nude you
gonna come in a little bit leaner you
want to run and being that you can't tie
up being at you a big man they don't
like to tie up I'm gonna work that
inside I'm gonna work that middle man
working right there every time you shoot
that jab move a parry and I'm sliding
and I'm shoot that right hand I'm gonna
give you a flashback of what I do best
fast hands
start hitting that new leaner body
starting those shoulders hitting those
elbows drop that hand down expose that
chin that is made in a china shop get
your head on a swivel make you panic
make you want to get out of that ring
make you quit inside and buy the fifth
round on dust you off because you no
longer want to beat it anyway so you
might get hit with something that's
whack and just lay down and stated now
we know the way in and we know Andy Ruiz
jr. came in at all-time high 283 points
something pounds boy are you out of your
mind this is the biggest fight of your
life you thought that first fight set
your family up this fight set your
family up for life and you did you did
have the audacity to come in it and a
severe obese 283 you disgust me man you
have a golden ticket you have that
opportunity you could be that face to
show everybody this ain't no rocky story
this says it's not that I'm built for
this AJ came in at a 235 236 slim lean
right all business the only one shake
old boy hand
he just wants smoke
so now we got these two combatants ready
to fight tomorrow night we already got
the weigh-in what did the King think
what did the King think I got Andy
psych Anthony Joshua 1011 for our
knockout Andy you missed the boat baby
this was just shot you in the mix now -
maybe you feel like okay I made it here
so not gonna fight other people I'll get
a third fight with Anthony nah dogs they
push you in the back and if you think
you got a shot at Deontay Wilder he's
gonna crack your skull it's combat talk
with the king catch y'all later
put those comments the light following
subscribe and also drawing hit that join
button this is on the zone tune in
[Music]